[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much donna and indeed
this morning saw the start of the work
of the new european union agency for
asylum the new agency expands on the
responsibilities of the former european
asylum support office
it will work in support of national
authorities towards fast and fair asylum
procedures and consistent reception
standards across the eu the agency is a
key deliverable of the new pact on
migration asylum and under its new
mandate it will be able to among others
quickly deploy operational assistance to
member states where a lot of people
apply for asylum create a permanent
asylum reserve pool of 500 national
officials
develop training practical guides tools
analysis it will establish an
independent fundamental rights officer
and it will also work closer with non-eu
partner countries to support capacity
building in line with international
standards
the new agency will receive 172 million
euro
in funds in 2022 and will launch eight
operations in belgium cyprus greece
italy latvia lithuania malta and spain
to support the asylum and reception
authorities in member states with almost
2 000 personnel
its new logo that you see behind me is
set therefore to become a familiar site
across the eu it is a deceptively simple
logo but it tells a story that i invite
you to discover on the agency's website
and for more more information in general
please also refer to our press release
thank you very much ad albert
[Music]
you are first go ahead
good afternoon from strasbourg
um i understand that the commissioners
breton reinders spoke to a couple of
meps on tuesday
about legislation
around
corporate
sorry people tell me to be silent
because i'm a press room here um about
corporate uh you do geologists uh on
human rights um this legislation has
been postponed several times but uh
seems to be scheduled now for the 15th
of february
i was wondering can you confirm this
thank you very much mates christianis
promptly
joined me
on stage to attempt an answer to this
question
yes thanks mates for your question
look i can say in more general terms of
course this is a very important
initiative
for for the commission
which we have now announced in our
work program last year
it will be an important
initiative for you know fostering
long-term viable and responsible
business business models
which incorporate climate environmental
considerations and are in line with
human rights
this is for the benefit of both
companies performance and
for our future generations
the preparations of this proposal are
are in full swing
as you said before
of course quality goes
before speed and
but we are working on this intensively
for the moment
the the proposal is scheduled uh in the
list of points
for mid-february as you know this is
always an indicative list
and we can only confirm um when a
proposal comes after the heads of
cabinets have discussed the agenda of
the of the college meeting as usual
but i can just say at this stage we that
work is intensively ongoing on this
proposal
thank you very much christian are there
any additional questions on this subject
i do not see any other any additional
questions for christian on the other
files that he covers as he is right now
on stage
that is not the case either thank you
very much christian and i will now open
the floor to other topics
the next person in line for me is lily
lily go ahead
yes we see that you are trying to
connect but we cannot connect
there you are
can you okay great thank you um i was
wondering if you could give us an update
on when was the last covet test that
commissioned president fender line took
and what was the outcome of that test
thank you
thank you very much for your question um
lilly as you surely know because the
president communicated herself on that
through social media
the president returned from strasbourg
to brussels on monday after it emerged
that
the her driver tested positive for
coronavirus
the president
i am happy to inform you is fully
vaccinated so she had her double
vaccination as well as a booster
according to the
belgian protocols
she and and to the french protocols as
well because she discovered that
situation while in france in strasbourg
the president doesn't need to um isolate
or to to current
but she
needs to apply uh preventive measures
which she applies very strictly so she
needs to wear a mask to follow social
distancing rules and to have no contact
with
vulnerable people for a number of days
over and on top of that the president is
testing regularly i can tell you that
she tested yesterday and today and i'm
happy to tell you that the result of the
test was negative
are there any additional questions on
this matter
i see a couple of hands up i wonder if
it's about that
no the hands are now down so that
indicates that we move to other subjects
so yes please now i open the floor to
other
topics and i see that sarah has a
question sarah go ahead
i understand sarah that you have no
mic source that
can work so can you give it another try
to select a right mic source
yes hi sorry
um so
yesterday the member states health
ministers conference included a
discussion of european hospital labels i
am just wondering what the commission's
position is on this european hospital
label please thank you
thank you very much sarah i will invite
stefan to
to attempt to provide you an answer to
this question
he's on his way
thank you very much for your question i
don't think i'm in a position to say
anything at this stage but i'll be happy
to come back to you
if i have more info to share
thank you very much but now stefan is on
the podium so i will invite you to raise
your hand if you have further questions
for him
on the panoply of matters that he covers
health related in particular
i do not see any questions for you
stefan so that was it for today i assume
thank you oh i'm sorry there is a
question over there please go ahead
um
hi i just wonder if you can give us an
update on the european health emergency
preparedness and response authority his
implementation
and budget
possible thank you
thank you very much sabina stefan
thank you
well thank you very much you know that
um indeed hair was already established
at the end of last year uh to tackle two
things two phases or to cover two phases
when we're dealing with pandemics on the
one hand the preparedness work uh on the
other hand the um the possibility that's
given to hera or should will be given to
hera we hope to act quickly when a
pandemic has actually struck i can tell
you that the work of hair is ongoing
hair is being developed obviously and in
particular it is working a lot on the
omicron virus it is in constant contact
with experts that continue to follow the
evolution of the omega environment it
has discussions with the vaccine
developers because as you know the
vaccine is and remains the main tool to
tackle
corona including its variants so these
discussions are also
very much ongoing and so hera is i would
say very much working on the
preparedness element
that has
been agreed already and that's part of
its mandate since the end of last year
but of course
further steps uh are important you know
that we also want here to have a quick
decision processes and work is ongoing
there as well thank you
thank you very much stefan are there any
additional questions
about this matter about hera
sabina has a follow-up question go ahead
sabina
what is the budget of this urgency
please
stefan do you have the figures
i don't have the figures in my head i'll
have to look into that um
obviously
budget budgets have been made available
for the work of hair but let me get back
to you on with with some more concrete
figures if that's right better to be
sure about the figures that we that we
give so that's why stefan is going to
check and provide you the information
immediately after the midday briefing
thank you stefan
are there any additional questions for
us today on other matters
yes mache
mache go ahead
the deadline finally final
deadline
passed yesterday say water walls are the
next steps by the european commission to
deduct
funds from poland thank you
thank you very much pancho this is not a
question for stefan so i'm going to
free stefan and i will
invite balash on stage to provide you
with information on the next steps in
relation
to
poland
good afternoon indeed um so for the very
first call for payment that the
commission sent on the 10th of november
uh to the polish authorities the
deadline expired uh yesterday this means
that the 14 uh the 45 plus 15 day
deadline
expired uh yesterday so the next step in
the procedure according to the financial
regulation is
the so-called off-setting procedure
i've had the opportunity in the recent
past to brief you about what that looks
like but just to give you again a short
summary of it what the commission needs
to do now is to identify a suitable um
or appropriate payment against which the
compensation
can be made once that's the case the
commission will inform the polish
authorities
about the outcome of this procedure
giving them a
time period of at least 10 days 10
working days to to submit
comments in relation to
this
measure
and following following that the
commission will deduct
the amount
concerned from the payment identified
thank you very much palash for outlining
the process are there any additional
questions on this measure poland the
the call for payment
that is not the case are there any other
questions for balash on the other files
that he covers
that is not the case either so thank you
very much balash i know catherine i
think it's you behind the mask
it is
thank you dad
um so my question i think it's for uh
peter if he's there but um yesterday
there was a briefing in the brussels
press club from the minister of foreign
affairs and deputy prime minister of
kazakhstan
mukhtar till birdie
and
he spoke about the recent protests and
what is described as what he described
as terrorist attacks
and
the ministers told us that he would be
meeting with people in the external
action service and do you have any
feedback on this and specifically
the european parliament will be tabling
a well have tabled a resolution to be
debated tomorrow
on uh the situation in kazakhstan and
what they have been calling for is an
independent investigation
can
can you say whether this is something
that you are calling for
because
i don't think
given that the the president said
publicly uh
issued a shoot to kill order
and that journalists um and uh
and independent media outlets were very
much restricted
following the protests
is this something that you're going to
demand thank you
thank you catherine and indeed peter is
here thank you catherine
um i can confirm that the high
representative was not able to and will
not be able to meet the kazakh foreign
minister and when it comes to other
meetings within the eas we usually do
not do not flag them if there are
meetings between the officials of the
eas with outside partners but we have
ongoing communication with our kazakh
partners both in kazakhstan itself
because we have new delegation their
member states are represented and also
when necessary bilaterally either in the
capitals of the eu member states or in
brussels um
when you mentioned the resolution or the
calls from the european parliament but
well i mean the european union and its
member states very very clear when it
comes to kazakhstan already a few days
after the unfortunate protest and
violence erupted on the i think 8th of
january there was a declaration by the
high representative on behalf of the
whole european union um condemning the
violence the unfortunate debts of
peaceful protesters and we said since
then that it is very important for
kazakhstan to credibly investigate the
events the eruption of violence the
reasons for it and also the way how it
was handled that we are condemning the
use of force and killings of peaceful
protesters and innocent loss of life and
the sooner kazakh authorities manage to
investigate this in a transparent manner
and explain also provide answers to the
international community the better for
kazakhstan itself because kazakhstan is
important partner for us as european
union kazakhstan is important actor in
the region is important for regional
stability and it's in the interest of
kazakh people to see that
this kind of events are not repeated
when people are being killed
for
protesting peacefully so we continue
monitoring situation in kazakhstan and
we continue our engagement with kazakh
partners in order to have full clarity
about the events what happened how it
happened and the necessary follow-up as
i said including the proper
investigation of the deaths of innocent
protesters and also explanations and
investigations of the detentions of the
peaceful protesters
thank you very much peter catherine you
have a follow-up
you forgot how it works it's working
it's been a while i forgot red means go
um yes so um my question my
i i just asked you if you you said that
you want a a credible
investigation and you said that the
catholic you want the catholic
authorities to carry out
that investigation um
in a transparent way but
is it really
uh realistic to expect that given what
what what has been happening should you
not be demanding an independent
investigation by an outside body of some
description thank you
the european union was very clear that
uh it would be for the benefit of
kazakhstan itself as a country and the
kazakh people to see a proper
transparent credible investigation and
being given answers to questions which
are linked to these unfortunate events
which we have been witnessing at the
start of january so it's up to the
kazakh authorities to provide these
credible answers how they do it is in
their hands at this stage we see no
signs that the kazakh authorities would
not be willing to investigate and would
not be willing to provide the necessary
answers and if the answers provided
later on will not be satisfactory then
it will be up to the member states again
to make their position known about what
they expect from kazakhstan but we are
now in a process of immediate aftermath
of the of the unfortunate events uh
kazakh authorities managed to stabilize
the situation we have seen the
withdrawal of the intervention forces
from the csto organization
uh the kazakh authorities are in touch
in contact in exchanges with us we are
monitoring the situation and we will
enter uh these uh engagements within
eventually new demands if necessary but
at this stage we see that there is
willingness and there is action on the
side of kazakh authorities to provide
those credible and transparent answers
thank you very much peter are there any
additional questions for peter on the
subject kazakhstan
no then on any other subjects which
peter covers
foreign affairs related
yes philippe
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
adama
you